[Music]
okay you got to get your holiday
shopping on
now that is the advice from the board of
los angeles it is a bottleneck at the la
in long beach ports and it's record
breaking 65 cargo ships are just sitting
there waiting to be unloaded look at
that video
experts say more spending a shortage of
delivery trucks and full warehouses has
led to a traffic jam at the ports
much volume coming into the port that
they
port workers and the cranes and
everything have been unable to handle
that level of throughput
well things are so backed up that
halloween costumes at the port haven't
even been unloaded yet all those
problems will create delays everything
from furniture to electronics to yes
those holiday toys
and a holiday staple may be harder to
find and more expensive this year
according to the american christmas tree
association supply chain disruptions are
causing an artificial tree shortage
retailers say the setback could
quadruple shipping costs and
unfortunately extreme weather events in
the pacific northwest have also taken a
toll on the nation's live christmas tree
supply
so here